when women go into a space and and you
kind of see it in this conversation
women don't like to have hierarchy and
rank each other so the same way I'll say
hey men don't like fat chicks some of
you are like okay yes true but then like
some other people are like well but oh
no women tend to like everything to be
more egalitarian Fair everyone's special
participation trophies so when women
infiltrate an industry it tends to get
more or it tends to get less competitive
what happened in education is they
started grading things like papers
homework essays and attendance which
kind of fluff up the grade where it used
to just be IQ tests